it's rare that I get to talk to somebody
who's now doing this the same kind of
gig that that I do so it's fascinating
I'm curious how it felt to you the first
time you walked through that curtain you
know that they said okay it's welcome
here's your host James Corden and though
you walked through the curtain for the
first time what was going through your
head well it's it's terrifying is the
truth
because the weirdest thing is when you
like taking over a show like this is for
the last sort of three months really
we've just been hiring a team to work on
the show myself and Ben Winston and Rob
Crabbe who are the execs on the show if
we literally arrive January 5th and it
was the three of us right and then we
just started to hire people and so I've
always felt like I this is a real team
effort we're a team because that is the
actual truth you know so much that it's
a team from everyone your wonderful band
everyone backstage these incredible
technicians if you're you're absolutely
in a team and then there comes so that
was what I was thinking oh we're all
making this show together and then just
one night I found myself like behind the
curtain with out with all of these
people who I thought were in it with me
going hey good luck man yeah yeah and
you look and like they're they're gone
and you're just on your own and all you
can see is this spotlight from the back
of the room on the curtain just this
circle and you just go oh this is going
to open in a minute I walk out there and
look remotely like I know anything about
anything and then it's just a quest to
not throw up on your own clothes yeah
the truth that won't last quickly oh I
don't know I even felt it then I was
talking to your guys do you have two
wonderful men who open your curtain
there when you don't have such big
budgets and I was saying I'm wearing the
wrong Underpants for this suit you know
when you're wearing you know they know
lagina when you're wearing it wrong when
you've got the wrong Underpants for the
trousers that I'm really in a sort of
chafed space that I don't feel I don't
feel a hundred percent comfortable in
it's alright sat down right but I don't
have to walk off to our you say goodbye
where we go I guess those two men come
out and they carry you yeah that's fine
you